a man accused of being part of a death
squad in the west african state of
gambia has gone on trial here in germany
their 46 year old came to germany as a
refugee and was arrested here last year
he is accused of being involved in
murders while working for an
assassination unit known as the junglas
the junglas took direct orders from
former dictator yaya james who ruled
gambia from 1996 until early 2017. the
german trial is the first in the world
to see human rights violations committed
in gambia during the jamai era
prosecuted on the basis of universal
jurisdiction under this a country can
prosecute crimes against humanity and
war crimes regardless of where the
atrocities took place
with me in the studio is nanajo endao
founder of anaked african network
against extrajudicial killings and
enforced disappearances her father was
forcibly disappeared and allegedly
killed by the junglas death squad she
attended the opening days of the trial
here in germany hello the nigel it's
nice to have you here so
how important is this trial for you and
other families of those who were killed
during the iaea dictatorship
this trial is extremely important for us
we've been fighting for justice
demanding accountability saying that
impunity is not okay we're seeing that
things are not moving in the gambia and
this is happening here the message is
very clear you you can commit crimes
anywhere in the world
you can try and hide if they find you
they will try you it doesn't matter
where those crimes took place especially
when you're talking about crimes against
humanity also evidence will come out
during this trial that we can use in
other cases and so we will be able
basically essentially to create a domino
effect to be able to try other
perpetrators that have committed crimes
during the yaya jaime era you say the
trial is important and rightfully so but
what impact is it happening in gambia
right now
so first let me talk about the victims
right the victims in the gambia
you know feel finally like the
things are moving might not be in the
gambia but you know the germany is
sending a message with this that
you this person came into our country
this person has committed all these
crimes in the gambia we will try this
person and
for us the victims were saying we're
going to show the government oh my
goodness they're doing this in the
gambia oh sorry in germany but you're
unable to do this in the gambia why is
that right also not many gambians are
aware that this trial is taking place
because it's taking place in germany
it's in german and so what we're trying
to do is disseminate this information
amplify our voices and say again that
this is what is happening this is what
this government is doing we need to hold
our government accountable and ask them
to do the same
so it's clear what your demand is
because it's not like the gambia hasn't
really done anything right gambia's
truth and reconciliation commission held
an inquiry into killings and torture and
uh yeah
but gambia hasn't prosecuted people who
admitted to committing these crimes how
does that make you feel
i mean
i am outraged the other victims are
completely outraged right some of these
people that have been
released
actually confessed to the crimes that
they committed
they confessed on live tv they've been
released
you know some victims bump into them
they are going to naming ceremonies
attending public events as if nothing
has happened others are also being you
know placed into position of power
the message that this is sending is that
you can commit these crimes and it's
fine you just come you just tell the
truth um shed a few tears and then you
go scot-free
you also have some of them who have been
reinstated into their previous positions
and we are completely outraged we're
saying that
this is not what we signed up for you
know president adam abao came in and
then his riding ticket was justice was
accountability was democracy and what
we're seeing is not what is happening in
the gambia
i mean while all this is going on uh
former president jamae is living in
exile in equity or guinea do you see any
chance of bringing him to justice
it's going to take a lot of time and
effort from us the victims
and also our allies the people who are
providing support
because the government of the gambia is
definitely not interested um as a matter
of fact adam a barrel um foreign
alliance with
yajam is a former party
but
we with all the work that we're doing
especially when you're seeing all these
prosecutions happening outside of the
gambia
the message is clear is that you know
accountability is inevitable and is
non-negotiable so you're optimistic
thank you